c'est l'exode rural est le refus de
laisser le village de la paix est dans
le haut jura se dépeupler qui a favorisé
la fondation d'une association destinée
à relancer son activité économique par
le biais du tourisme
particularité de cette association ce
sont uniquement les gens du village qui
dirige la garde puisque tel est son nom
qui a donné de bons résultats en huit
ans d'activité
une enquête réalisée la station de ski
de fond de l'appel par véronique
marchand et les chars mas situé à égale
distance de lamoura et d'oyonnax dans la
partie sud du haut jura
le petit village de la ps a subi au fil
des ans a crevé à l'exode rural passant
de 1000 habitants en 1836 à 200 en 76 à
cette même époque l'essor du ski de fond
a déjà un impact sérieux alors quelques
villageois décident de réagir trouver
une activité capable de retenir la
population
ce sera le tourisme avec comme cible le
ski de fond on crée donc une association
loi 1901 l'agad dont le conseil
d'administration est uniquement composé
de gens du village
travaillant en étroite collaboration
avec la municipalité l'agad s'occupe de
gérer et transformé des bâtiments en
lieu d'accueil pour touristes ainsi
l'hôtel du village passe de 25 à 40
chambres et six centres d'accueil sont
aménagés pour accueillir 300 vacanciers
l'agad germes et propose et organise par
exemple des stages de ski de fond sous
niveau des raids avec des chiens de
traîneaux l'accueil des classes de neige
mais aussi celui des classes vertes car
on était les activités sont nombreuses
douze emplois permanents et trente
saisonniers ont été créés par la gamme
qui a contribué à faire passer la
population de 200 à 230 habitants un
résultat bien proche du but fixé le chou
6 à 8 ans des gens qui ont créé
l'association c'est effectivement de
relancer l'économie locale
d'une part par le soutien économique
direct sur le commerce d'autre part
éventuellement par l'emploi évidemment
justement la ga devons gère différents
aux établissements mais son autre
activité et de mettre en place des
services comme par exemple des stages de
ski et puis il y en a d'autres exemples
vous voyez c'est à dire que les centres
d'accueil qui sont là pour l'accueil de
groupes d'individus elle de famille etc
ça correspond un petit peu à un outil de
travail à partir desquels on peut
construire et proposer des séjours sous
forme de stages de tous niveaux
initiation perfectionnement compétition
formation hiver avec essentiellement le
ski l'été avec d'autres activités
estivales
l'association c'est les gens du village
l'originalité de l'association c'est que
en sont membres actifs membres de droit
la population locale qu'il le souhaite
évidemment peut pas imposer sincères
correspond pratiquement deux tiers de la
population active de l'appétit pour
l'instant et c'est important tout ce qui
se passe dans le domaine du
développement touristique notamment est
maîtrisée par la population locale et
c'est sale c'est ça c'est ça qui est
intéressant
si à la garde on préfère rester modeste
et prudent vont du résultat obtenu
d'autres projets avancent celui
notamment de développer l'artisanat peut
être sous forme de scop par exemple
parce qu'à la paix sont considère que le
développement local ne doit pas
s'arrêter à celui du ski et même du
tourisme c'est toute la vie et
l'économie du village que la cades
compte améliorer